fifteen Brophy ignition these were the
first few seconds of what will be an
ambitious seven-year long mission to
unlock the secrets of our closest star
three two one zero
liftoff mounted on a delta 4 heavy
rocket as high as a 23-story building
the first objective for the NASA Parker
Solar Probe was to achieve escape
velocity of around 25,000 miles an hour
but eventually as it nears the Sun and
enters its corona it'll become the
fastest ever man-made object reaching
speeds of four hundred and thirty
thousand miles an hour or 120 miles a
second so if you could've think of the
Sun and the earth as a victim right now
we don't know the physics that really
are powering the solar winds we know an
awful lot about the Sun and we know
about the solar wind from spacecraft
that's it even if closed with mercury
and so we need to get in there and
explain what's really going on and then
we'll be able to put all that physics
into our models and we'll make such huge
transformational improvements in our
ability to predict how the earth is
impacted by the Sun its first port of
call in November of this year will be
the planet Venus and scientists are
confident that its first brush with a
Sun will follow in November protected by
a revolutionary new carbon heat shield
the aim is for the probe to make 24
close approaches of the Sun's corona
second to the plane it was 60 years ago
that professor Eugene Parker after whom
the probe is named predicted the
discovery of solar winds but it's only
now that technology has advanced enough
to make such a mission possible he and
his family were at Cape Canaveral to
witness the launch he wrote a paper
where he actually predicted that we
would see a solar wind we would see this
atmosphere continually streaming away
from the planet from the Sun and bathing
all of the planets and his paper were
kind of controversial at the time but it
turned into a landmark seminal paper
that's really kind of given birth to all
of the science that we heliophysics as
we call ourselves that's what we do it's
all based on the work of Jean Parker
heads hope the probe will reveal more
about the sun's life-giving but often
violent nature and why it's corona is
hotter than its surface one of the solar
systems great mysteries Phil Edwards Sky
News